he's the hall-of-famer Clippers
consultant of course former Laker GM and
player Jerry West joining us on the
program Jerry is that a real background
there I'm sorry is that a real
background is that you got palm trees
behind you yes
actually I've been in Palm Springs for
about two and a half months and it's
getting a little hot down here it's
about ready to head back to Los Angeles
here very soon a happy birthday by the
way is is the best gift to not bring up
that it's your birthday well then I
guess I've been fortunate to be around
for 82 years and also its my anniversary
so I thought it would be best to get
married on my birthday so I'd never
forget it but I did forget at one time a
lot of that for size
what happened just in the middle of a
season and sometimes when you get there
you just birthdays when they were never
important when I when I grew up and I
guess it was just a minor thing and more
importantly you know it was just
something it wasn't important and I
guess as you go along today and been
involved and obviously a few people know
me I've gotten a lot of notes and
everything and it's really nice to hear
from people at this point into your life
and this is your 40th wedding
anniversary so 40 years ago
how many NBA players showed up for your
wedding I don't know if any did 40 K
actually is 42 dad all 42 years ago all
right okay so you didn't have teammates
who showed up for your wedding oh no no
this was this was well after my career
and I mean deploying days and it wasn't
a huge wedding anyway but anyway a lot
of a lot of crazy things I've seen in my
life in my 82 years of time that's this
year well happy birthday how how many
conversations have you had with Clippers
players or Doc Rivers or anybody Steve
Ballmer with the possibility of when we
come back actually a number Dan we like
all teams I'm sure we've had a lot of
like this going on we have try to have a
guest each week that provides some
insight on some of the things they've
done as athletes very successful people
and issues that they've gone through in
their lives and and really talking about
how do how do you keep yourself
motivated during this period of time
when there's so much uncertainty around
but at the end of the day I think these
conversations have helped because they
keep people alive
and I think more importantly here's some
people have had enormous success in
their respective fields in their lives
yeah we're trying to figure this out and
then I don't know what safeguards are
put in place and can we put everybody in
Orlando and how many teams do we take
playoff wise do you have suggestions on
that of do we make it 20 because there's
four teams that are closer in the West
for that final playoff spot well Dana I
think first of all to me and I've said
this before and I don't know what they
all do but I think they need to have a
lease teams should play at least 72
games okay because it's only 12 less
than the regular season and also it
gives a team that are on the bubble and
trying to make the playoff it'll give
them a chance to get in there and
compete at a high level to try to get
into the playoffs and then I'm not sure
how the playoff format would work or not
would they expand a little bit more I
think the most awkward thing and the
questions we asked all these really fun
people that we that we've been involved
with great players and a lot of respect
to you feels what their advice might be
and you know the one thing I think most
people don't realize when you're trying
to stimulate your players and keep them
involved with with their friends and
also their teammates it's communication
and the league is communicating as much
as they can there's a lot of things they
have to take in consideration here but
this is obviously Dan an awkward time in
trying to figure out what the dynamics
are going to be people are talking about
playing in a bubble with
with both with no fans I'm not sure how
they could do it in one place to me that
would be better to let the teams in the
West say play in Las Vegas whether its
facilities there plenty of hotel rooms
and in Orlando keep the teams in the
East that would make it a little bit
easier I think also to satify the
contents of our relationship with ESPN a
relationship with TNT and all our
providers who are broadcasting the games
were people who are frankly starving for
competition yeah I'm with you I thought
that they were gonna do you know like a
satellite city and have it in Las Vegas
and have the West Coast teams play there
and then have the East Coast teams play
in Orlando the question would be then
where do you play the NBA championship I
guess you could have one team go to
Orlando or Vegas what about the
possibility that you could have a Lakers
Clippers NBA Finals if we're just gonna
seed it 1 through 16 and not have the
East Coast West Coast Jerry well well
from made and that would be the ultimate
competition I think in Los Angeles you
know they have so many Laker fans my
goodness the enormous success of the
Lakers have had over the years they have
a really good team now you know two of
the best players we've seen in a long
time on one team I think would be
incredible or the team of the people in
the West I'm not sure how that would go
over for for the teams back east who
want to see their respective teams get
an opportunity to play but that would be
a situation where I think it would be
unbelievably competitive it would be
compelling that I don't know how many
teams in the same city have competed for
championship in any sport much less than
the NBA but it's a it would make a
compelling story but you know a
likelihood I think you're going to see
things that are that'll be a little bit
more normal without offending any the
team we have a lot of team this legatus
about one or two teen alig is comprised
of all of the teams all the players and
what you want more importantly what you
want you want competition a bit against
the best teams we're talking to Jerry
West the Hall of Famer Clippers
consultant did you see the last dance
the Bulls documentary you know I did you
know a lot of this subbed and I knew
about you know I knew some of the
partners I mean a lot of employers
obviously because I was very really
involved in and also knew Jerry Krause
and I'm you know I'm known the Reinsdorf
for years and I've always really liked
Jerry and Jerry Krause at one time had
worked with us and you know his there's
some people that have been hurt in this
documentary I don't think there's any
question and it's probably some hard
feelings but it was pretty raw at times
the language if you listen to it was was
offensive for some people but that's
really the way the players talk to each
other in the locker not so it's become
much more prevalent it wasn't like that
when I played and it it was because
people you know Michael I love Michael
okay he's one of my best best buddies in
terms of never changing he does not
change okay he's a fun-loving guy he's
compassionate and I think you conceded a
really competitive part come out of him
but he also I think some of this stuff
gets you know when you see the real raw
part of it a lot of was getting and
everything because he does like the kid
and I'm not trying to defend him from
people who look at him as anything other
than this iconic player but there's you
know Scottie Pippen to me it was damaged
in this because they made a point to
talk about a couple things in his career
that certainly weren't what you'd like
to see and I never thought it I'm sure
he feels horrible about it then
Gary Krause who dissing a nice guy and
who had done a very good job Chicago
because become almost pinata for
Christ's sake yeah
hitting throw things at it throughout
derogatory remarks and when you have
success success players are the ones who
bring the ultimate success but someone
has got to put those pieces together and
I also thought it was with Phil Jackson
there as a coach I'm not so sure any
coach could have handled that situation
except him you know Dennis leaving
someone I do really like Dennis myself
him leaving going to a WWF wrestling
thing body slamming someone then going
back and playing games I'm not so sure
any coach could handle this except for
when I watch the Jordan documentary it
just brought back what Kobe like Kobe
never shied away from being the next
Michael he wanted to be better than
Michael Jordan mannerisms the way he
talked the way he played similar-sized
there did you ever talk to Kobe about
you know that or did you know that he
wanted to be Michael Jordan
well then almost everything he did you
could watch him in practice and you say
oh my gosh I've seen Michael do this
I've seen Michael do that but I really
think their crowning moment to that the
real crowning moment and when Michael
first jumped up on the bench the benches
were they the staff are the writers are
right fourth side there he jumped up and
started this very exuberant celebration
you know who did that Kobe Bryant
exactly the very same thing and I think
he admired him so much he admired how he
played and also the enormous success he
had both as a as a team but also as an
individual and you're talking about
players that
obviously wired differently you hear
some of the incredible players that play
the game today in all sports and just
see how they're really different they
are in their pursuit of excellence and
certainly his pursuit of excellence was
but just like Michaels yeah cuz guys
wanted his so to shy away from hey grant
Hills the next Michael Jordan Tracy
McGrady's the next Michael Jordan and
forney heart Kobe was the only one to
say bring it on like I want that and I
always had money he never shied away
from that and I mean that it's pretty
incredible that he didn't shy away from
that possible comparison or that title
if you knew him at an early age that's
who he was he was so committed and so so
driven you know he would go play
basketball anyplace against anyone and
every year every practice you're gonna
see something different out out of him
and for a while it was a problem because
it's not an individual game
individuals win can win game for you and
big in a lot of a lot of players don't
want the pressure the really good ones
bring it on and that's who he became
when he learned how that the nuance of
the game to tony's game down a little
bit so he so you could have a team
instead of an individual but late in the
game and times when you needed a basket
he was going to get it for you
just as Michael Jordan did but his
infatuation with him was far greater
than most people know I think Michael
talked about in the documentary some how
they communicated and that thing it toad
shows you that there are certain people
in this world are the leaders and have
certain people that have the same kind
of desire to reach that status and it's
a learning process you just don't pick
it up immediately
it takes time also it takes success and
a belief that people that you're playing
with
and this
just as you have that people want to
follow that but only a few people can
follow you you can be the greatest
competitor in the world you can be the
greatest trainer you hear this
Kobe mentality the mentality of a
Michael there's tons of players out
there that have that same mentality Dan
but they don't have the ability to be
able to go out and and dominate again
you know they can have great games but
they can't dominate games and they can't
dominate it's easy like certain players
do did you keep any of your jerseys -
good stuff remember because you don't
strike me as a guy who's gonna keep
memories or memorabilia but I'm just
curious know you I have no idea where
that stuff you get right now and I guess
if anyone sent you anything that would
have any significance you'd have it out
there but oh yeah I never collected an
of anything you know I just say if you
come in my house you would not see maybe
one or two things that might remind you
that I was a player and yesteryear and
I've always been that way to me it was
about and he played you played for the
city he played for the organization and
you played to have success and all of
those things for me were what drove me
and my career
and you know I look back and you know
what's these guys today with all and
Kobe and Michael obviously Michael I
think first started at his desire to get
fitter stronger and be able to compete
against the Pistons for who were
notoriously physical and at that point
in time I think their presence in the
league probably helped change a league
for both some of the fouls that they
committed were very hard but this had
gone on for years because of Detroit
success
certainly
they didn't care who it was your Fanny
was gonna be in there ground if you're
in the air long for later but they
helped change the rules to be honest
with you but Michael Michael started
this you can see the difference in him
in a couple of years this how just how
big I'm a bigger he got leaner looking
and I don't think I've ever seen an
athlete like him that has ever been that
explosive and the quickness and his
ability to run I read somewhere that
Michael said he like he ran like a 4 314
yeah and he wasn't even pushing it I'm
saying to myself how can you have that
kind of running ability and the enormous
quick leaping ability had I don't know
what it vertical was but it was
ridiculous but the skill involved just
put him in another class yeah not fair
happy birthday my thanks to your lovely
wife Karen for all that she's done over
the years and setting up these
interviews we always appreciate your
time and hopefully we get some
basketball and Thank You Jerry
and always great to speak to you that we
need set we need something it's time the
world that's that's the great Jerry West
Hall of Famer turning 82 today and
celebrating his wedding anniversary as
well